[Music]
we've uh
we're at one o'clock so to clear
our meeting open
at 4 30 today we're
going to be if we are still going at
that point um we'll be having a briefing
as you've been
made aware
so firstly i've got um apologies from
council duty and also councillor stewart
sarah
prepared to move that
moved council debate seconded um
could you please just face yeah you
could start
start from there on no no no face them
to the center to out to the center so
everyone can see them but it is
it's um
but staff please just take a note of
that for the future thank you council
redmond
thank you
i'll
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to declare it carried
any conflicts of interest for today's
meeting
if there is just let us know
um
thank you there's no acknowledgements
that i've been made aware of
so come to the confirmation of minutes
pages
18 to 30 and also extraordinary meeting
on the 9th of november pages 31-32 i'll
take those separately
council blackie are prepared to move
those are true and correct records
secreted by council award
um i'll put that all those in favor
please say aye
contrary to clear it carried item 4.2
um pages 31 to 32 counts though that's
moving signature councillor brian
i'm sure you're happy with that i'll put
those all those in favor please say i
can't try to clear it carried are there
any measures arising from the minutes
okay so we'll deal with the px minutes
um
uh when we come to those uh later in the
agenda
so we've got deputations and
presentations we've got mr is mr inward
with us
hi greg do you want to come forward to
the table
yes that's fine yes
so if we um
welcome you to our meeting greg i'll
just let you get set up here
um you've got a microphone there in
front of you if you wouldn't mind
clicking that on
uh there should be no no sorry
there's a green there's a
grey button at the front
yep yeah just press the grate
that's it
beautiful
so we've got up to 10 minutes for you
greg to talk around the issues that you
want to talk to us about regarding
development contributions and if you can
leave some time that would be
appreciated so
thank you and thank you mr mayor and
fellow councillors for allowing me to
come along and speak to you uh with just
with regard to this
little situation that i have
just to give you a little bit of
background greg and what's my name i've
resided in woody since 1988 and i'm a
small fried developer down in the
southeast part of wood end
it's had its battles over the years and
it seems like they just keep continuing
but never mind that's what we do in life
sometimes um
really with the advent of covert it was
necessary for us to apply for an
extension to our current uh consent
which we did
in april 2020 which was duly passed
and with covert sort of gripping us and
a lot of unknowns i took the step to
basically break down one of our final
stages into
smaller stages so as instead of us
stalling for the growth of our
communities
into the future it gave me some options
around
doing it in a smaller piecemeal type
fashion
so at that stage in april of this year
i applied for a
variation to consent to basically
substage stage seven
which took
essentially
about 13 lots and broken into about four
little bite size
in doing so
we were then granted a um
a variation of consent
decision decision in the april
of this year
and
and in that
it was it was highlighted
as part of our
um
what would you call it
decision
on our resource consent application
on pages
eight it lists all our development
contributions
that are connected to that variation of
consent
the problem i have is i've just
developed just two sections as stage 7a
and received the bill of twice the
consents
from the from your council
um
two things one is i obviously
naturally got hold of the council said
look i think you've made an error
and could they please just
reissue that invoice and got quoted um a
whole lot of
sub-regulations and
parts 4b point c and
all the rhetoric that goes with it and
told that no they cannot alter the
invoice that is the invoice um i cannot
be off um given a two to four
certificate unless i pay that invoice in
full
now obviously
two issues here one is i believe the
development contribution should be as
per my consent and not citing a small
somewhere in some fine print that gives
the council the ability to
redo the cons the contributions
particularly with doubling the cost of
them
i think that's grossly unfair
particularly regarding no communication
around that
the second issue i have is that
it seems such a shame
that
as the
general public i don't have an ability
to communicate with the council and your
staff
around trying to resolve this issue
[Music]
directly
just with communication rather than
being happy to be granted a deputations
meeting today and address the likes of
the whole of the council i'm sure your
time could be spent far more effectively
making far more important decisions than
something that possibly could be done
in-house
so consequently that's where i'm at is
we've i've paid the bill
um
and
i'm not happy with it i just want to pay
the contributions as per my consent
and i'd be grateful if if you could
reflect on that and my invoice could be
adjusted accordingly and that money i
don't want it back it can just be held
until we do another stage
to pay for the the future consents that
are coming up
that's
uh pretty much it in a nutshell really
i'm open to any questions should you
have any thank you uh mr have you got uh
in writing your
points that you've made there
uh i'm only referencing the actual
consent okay because
i've taken the record of that yeah i
think the outcome of this is what we
would normally do with the deputation is
request a report to come back to council
so you've made your points there thank
you would you like the resource consent
number would that be um i think i think
we've probably got that detail there um
but if you've got that if you can maybe
just give it to tear before you leave
which
any questions of colleagues
council redmond
ah thanks greg
i see you've got a good jaguar face mask
oh yeah
well well noted
was there any reason given why there was
a departure from your original consent
uh no just cited some sub-clause that
said that the council have the right
when a consent is
extended or varied they have the right
to basically charge whatever the
relevant contributions are now of the
day
and i was totally unaware of that at the
time of of getting both the time
extension and the variation extension so
sort of come out of the blue
furthermore
they have
insisted that i actually connect my
existing dwelling
even though i'm subdividing two other
sections and when you've lived in a home
for 30 odd years and you've got
established gardens
there's a lot involved in in being able
to put in a low pressure sewer system
into an existing garden with established
oak trees and the like and large water
tanks so
i sort of agreed and also having to be
charged for
the contribution some twenty thousand
dollars to connect my own home at this
stage when my consent also states that i
have a time frame in which the existing
dwelling is to be connected to the
services
i just feel it's a little rigid
does that answer your question
any further questions
counselor
you've got all this documented
you know since april your
council from staff have got that so did
we get everything
uh yeah well it's only happened in the
last um week and a half this um this
invoice that come out of the blue for
the for the um
just
the development contributions being a
lot greater than what my consents show
yes so it's there's not been a lot of
there's only been a couple of emails
going backwards and forwards and they
were very rigid at stating their their
policies or um regulations and
basically pay up or or we're not you
know you won't get a 2 4 you won't get a
sign off you won't get this you won't
get that so
so where i'm going with that question is
i just want to make sure that i get
everything including what's happened in
the last week and a half sure
yeah you need to go back through your
staff which is a library
sorry i can't pronounce the lady's name
correctly
what would be helpful just following off
and council brian's questions is if you
could put a summary together
from your perspective of what's what's
going on and it would be helpful to have
that in writing from you sure if because
that's on the basis that we would call
for a report we just want to make sure
that we've collected all your
all your points and your concerns
accurately so that our staff can then
produce a report to come here and when
that does happen
you'd be most welcome be like the
february-ish
time frame you'd be most welcome to come
back to the council sorry what are you
sure
what's that sorry usually
oh it probably would be px yes correct
um
it would be public excluded actually yes
you're right thank you cheers uh council
bart
hey greek it's good to see you
um just a question about the process so
when you had a
concern about the fees that you're being
charged did you at any stage ask to
speak to a manager or arrange a meeting
with someone uh yes i i come in to the
office
to speak to somebody and nobody was
available um
that was a bit of a
an interesting situation i was a little
upset that day that nobody was here to
actually speak to
and then then somebody went to another
building and found somebody to talk to
me but it wasn't the right person um and
it's then there's been communication via
email from there so i have a copy of the
transcripts on the emails right but you
hadn't made an appointment with a
manager or anything to see a particular
person do you just come in i tried
and then through
through actually the response from the
council staff they basically told me my
only
form of of being able to take this any
further that their hands were tired was
to to go to this process here and they
recommended this process to me
was a little surprising i thought we
could
manage this in-house given that i've
dealt with the council for a good number
of years and consider myself to be a
person that's open to communication and
resolving issues sure that would be
great if you could write that all down
thank you sure
thank you um council williams
yeah when you say there's a variation to
it there's only a time variation is that
correct no the time variation was the
first one back at covert time because
our
original consent was about to expire
um and we we had started works but we
halted works with um
with covert and then i applied for in
april of this year i got consent uh
granted for a variation to break the
stage down into smaller bite size
just because we didn't know where covert
was going i mean as it turns out the
market's gone gangbusters but i mean um
you know
i'm more about doing it properly and a
bit more passion driven than i am about
just making the money so
i stick with my decision piecemeal so
you're going to do less now and some
more later on well it gives us the
ability to to break it down into more
comfortable um bite-size amounts to be
truthful paul i'm just at a stage of
life where i want to actually enjoy
doing what i do
and
i'm more passion driven and that's
i want to do it properly i've enjoyed
building our community down there at
copper beach it's it's a beautiful
subdivision we don't have six foot
fences around everything it's a lot of
plantings
and it's something i'm extremely proud
of and i'd like to see it to its
conclusion done properly your time in
life must be the same age as meeting
yeah
um what i was meaning
was
uh the next stage if there's the next
stage where that's going to be the same
cost or that can be reduced because
there may be an extra bigger
contribution for
a smaller lot you know what i mean no no
because we're residential for a um as
per our consent they're all stated what
the eastern um
sewer and the wooden sewer the odpa and
bits and pieces it's all detailed so
there's no
benefit or advantage or disadvantage of
me doing this it's more around it's more
around just doing it properly really
any further questions
so i think
i think really what
really see happened first i think
through you jim is actually to see um if
mr irmwood could meet with a senior
manager and see if matters could be
resolved
if reaches an impasse then a report to
come back to council for a direction i
think that's the direction of travel i'd
like to see are we all in agreement with
that
kelly
it's a bit out of order you're speaking
but you're welcome to come forward to
the table
sorry it's um the policy this it's real
a matter of the fact that our policy
requires us to to reassess this so staff
don't have delegation to vary from from
the policy so
um i do think it needs to be a report
that comes back to us that's fine i just
was seeking first and the first instance
of the senior manager could meet
um which i think is appropriate
that that occurs through the chief
executive and if that can't be resolved
then it comes back by way of a report
and from what you're saying it seems
that that may not be
easily able to be achieved without it
coming back with a report and i just
want to make it clear to mr emma that
regardless of a report coming back it
can't guarantee that uh you an outcome
that's going to depart from our present
policy we note what you're saying but i
just want to be really clear
that that report will weigh up options
and come to us i just want to i guess
manage that expectation for you but in
the first instance would be um to seek
an engagement with a senior manager and
see where that goes and then a report
that will come forward to us and that
probably wouldn't likely be till
february that we would be able to get a
report back
at this time but it would be helpful if
you can
put
put together a summary
and provide that and i'll get um tia to
make contact with you around
who's the right person to get that um
who's the right point of contact for you
to get that into all right okay so
somebody will confirm with me regarding
who's the summary is to be directed to
we'll get one of our governance staff in
touch with you
you thank you for that
okay thank you for your time mr elmwood
oh thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity appreciate it okay thank you
all right um we are now come forward to
attuned business and we've got two
reports to consider
i'll just let mr mwood
thank you
yeah that's relief
taking the mask off than us
thank you
oh
oh that's fine um understand um
[Music]
so
well
hopefully we will be through business
before 4 30 today and can i just stay
with these next two reports and thanks
jared for
being present for those joanne's unwell
and has sent through an apology
um
that just bear in mind um these two here
are going to be coming
um this is for the low cost low risk
program albeit it's recommending budget
that will be considered um
comprehensively at the time of the
annual plans it's not committing council
to a direction today it's just
pushing that into the annual plan
process as part of that so
um jared if you could take us through
that i just wanted just to highlight
that at the outset so that
whilst there'll be a lot of questions if
if this is followed through
um there will be another opportunity for
that to be properly considered as part
of the annual plan thank you
uh so there's two two reports and um the
first one i'm talking to is the low-cost
low-risk
report and i've just handed out some
revised recommendations and i'll just
draw your attention to the
the changes from the previously
circulated report have been highlighted
in
yellow
so just as a bit of a quick reminder
waka kotahi
fund us through
three different areas so
there's maintenance operations and
renewals which is the subject of the
next report
and then there's low cost low risk so
that's the new assets
and improvements
for projects under two million dollars
and the report that's in front of you is
the
is this category i mean there is
significant projects which uh projects
above two million um and then they're
not they're not subject to either of
these reports today but just as a bit of
a reminder there
so um just
in terms of uh the
recommendation it's probably worth just
drawing your attention to
recommendation g
so what
we're saying is
in this is that yeah requesting that you
put the tuahiri footpath and townsend
road culvert extension as two top-up
projects and i'll explain that in a
little bit more um as i
introduce it other than that it's
predominantly just explanations
of things to help provide a bit more
context
the so just just a
quick refresh the low cost low risk
funding
is for
some improvements in our eroding network
and as follow is broken down into a
series of classes of activities so
there's road to zero walking and cycling
improvements local road improvements
state highway improvements public
transport improvements services and
public transport infrastructure
and
we actually submitted a bid of 13.2
million
to waka katahi as part of the 21 2124
nltp bid
and wakakotahi have come back and
endorsed funding of 6.6 million leaving
about leaving a 6.6 million funding gap
um
and it's also worth noting um that there
is a likelihood that further funding
will come available over the three years
so at the moment they've gone out to all
of the councils and said here's your
allocation if for some reason
some councils don't deliver their
program or some of those projects fall
off then that may free up funding and
that's actually a realistic expectation
that over the coming years some of that
may free up and we may be able to
actually put in
bids for some of that funding as it
comes up
so anyway the um
so where we do have some discretion as
those
because i'm sure you'll you'll want to
know that it's really those
those townsend road and the
tour heavy footpath program projects
where you've got discretion the other
projects have been
approved by waka kotahi that we've
already got on the list um
and but if you wanted us to put other
projects up we do have the ability to do
that so if if you wanted to swap
um i towns in road or two here we
footpath for something we can do that um
two here we footpath townsend road or
any other project they're all going to
be subject to us being able to put a
case to wakakotahi to get that approved
um
and
i think it's uh we've also made some
allowance for getting on with the design
of some of the projects that are not
necessarily approved and that's to make
sure that we're on a front foot
if um we do get the opportunity to uh
take advantage of any funding that gets
freed up by waka katahi in the current
in the coming years
and the other thing is anything that has
not been
allocated out of that that original um
12 million we're saying we shouldn't be
just taking it off the table they should
be pushed out beyond the three years so
the council's still got the ability to
bring bring those back into the future
now i know this has been subject to
quite a bit of conversation with the
council so i won't go on
anymore i'm happy to take any
uh questions uh um regarding this thanks
jared so the yellow
the recommendation that's come around is
different than what was circulated in
our paper
so
so it's got the where the yellows are
inserted the other different parts that
you're suggesting that's right the
yellow is the chain are the changes
they're the addition so g which
is a new g um
which is around tuahue footpath and
townsend road culvert extension
i had understood that they would be
considered as part of the annual plan in
the broader picture when it comes back
to the council in february is that that
that's different than what's been
recommended here
uh yes but the those if you if you are
not there's there's three options for
you i think for that one is you can say
yes
you'd like us to go ahead with that um
the second option is
ask us to bring that back to the annual
plan so you can make a decision at that
meeting on those um or the third would
be to make a decision about swapping
those out so that is definitely an
option that's available
we can bring that back i think i think
the words are inconsidered
during the annual plan just gives that
broader picture that colleagues need to
see if the whole picture not just being
in piecemeal so
i think that's sort of the direction of
travel we did discuss during the
workshop when we discussed this matter
so in the briefing so
is there any other changes in this
wording that
would have a budgetary implication
beyond what we've already talked of
apart from g
no g is the only one that has a
uh abiding free implication so we could
we could make g um
sub due to approve subject to um
confirmation as part of the draft annual
plan
i think yeah i think that would be wise
but that'll be obviously that's a live
matter for the council any other
questions colleagues uh council meetings
all about council williams
jared just with regard to
the saying here
that
it's likely for the funding might become
available in c um for the small walking
and cycling initiatives and school
safety projects
um i'm particularly interested in the
impact on the
proposed
path shared use path down
tram road for swattanoa school students
do those fall under that category
and also i'm a bit concerned with the
emission of so many projects on tram
road
particularly the south air tram giles
road one how much are those rural
intersection active warning signs each
because every day i go online to
community pages and every day there are
near misses there every single day
and it's
it's concerning so i just wonder if the
cost
if the benefit might outweigh the cost
so i think the first part is yes that
would come under a minus safety um
this
small walking and cycling initiatives i
think that would be the case um
second part
we had actually in our original bid we
had allowed for more of the types of
interventions that you talk about
and
i can't i can't give you a figure off
the top of my head of exactly how much
they cost but we have carried out those
estimates for specific
projects
um and
if there's particular ones you want us
to look at before we come back to the
annual plan meeting we're happy to do
that and give a bit more information
yeah well i guess the particular ones
would be
that
the path on tram road
shared youth use path
for walking and cycling to swananoa
school
and the
um
intersection what do you call it the
rural um
yeah
giles tram self-air road
intersection
warning lights
thank you
yeah that raises a good question likely
funding coming the source
why would we approve this here in
council there and
maybe possibly improve those safety
lights and scenario
and then all of a sudden likely funding
comes available
oh we don't need to fund those lights
because the council's already paid for
them
so you know the the priority down the
the list would sort of drop because we
would actually fund a lot of that itself
and possibly
um the funding may may become available
as what you've said and the other
question is land transport thoughts
they've seen all this
why don't they think that is important
um actually that's a really good
question hopefully they'll help clarify
things so we're not saying progress
with the construction of projects if
there's no co-funding available
what we're
saying is we should be
progressing with
investigations and design
so that should funding become available
we're in a position to move on that so
if we haven't carried out some of that
initial work we wouldn't then have the
opportunity to get that money if it
becomes available so we're not actually
talking about um
spending any council money and putting
that at uh risk um it's really getting
ourselves in the best position so that
should any funding come available uh
we can uh take advantage of that so um
it's definitely not saying we'll fund
any of these at a 100
level
so none of this is actually for actually
doing work physical works it's just all
bureaucratic work
there's six million dollars
of physical work
that's proposed of of projects that have
been approved in the program we'd put a
bid in for 12. um
six has been approved and
the
intention is to deliver that over the
three years
and
progress with it as soon as we can with
an early early on in that three year
window as possible so that we do have
the ability to um
potentially take advantage of any more
funding that comes available later on in
the three years i thought you're asking
for
possibly an additional budget of 445.000
i'm really really confused now when
you're talking six million odd
dollars here i thought was progressing
some work towards
what's on this recommendation this is
the recommendation
yes that is correct and that is for the
you're quite correct that is subject to
the annual plan decision which would be
in the 22
and 23 year onward
the second part of my question
why the land transport of thought and
their safety things have been removed
from their budgets
they've just they it's
quite simply they have only got so much
money to go around
and
that's effectively what it's come down
to so we're not the only council
impacted by this this is happening
throughout the entire country i i
realize that but they must have done
some statistics why this physical stuff
here is not that important to the safety
of the roads compared with other things
they've funded perhaps chief executive
might be able to relay the meeting we
had with nicole rosie along with mr
cleary
what's the clarity
wakakotahi runs an investment
prioritization system so
every bid that comes up from every
council in each of the activity classes
is assessed against two or three factors
one is strategic fit the other is cost
benefit
and that's a nationally ranked program
so the point jared's making is with the
money that we've
put in our budget we can use some of
that for design so
their objective at the end of three
years is to spend all that money so if
somebody's lagging in an area
and we're ready to go then they could
well unlock some funding which is why we
can progress some of the designs it
helps us in that regard
it's a blackie founded by counts for the
bank
yeah my question was largely covered by
nikki nikki in her question but carrying
on just a little bit talking about that
giles road south air road corner if we
tick this off and see um
item f um and push that out three years
um she asked about the price i ever have
seemed to remember those flashy signs
were talked about a 40 grand
each i think so there'd be two or
something like that
if we took that us off does that
preclude us spending a couple of grand
on a ordinary sign or does
just the fact that we've ticked it off
means nothing's going to happen on that
intersection
assuming no more funding comes through
for three years
um so if there were some low cost very
you know substantially lower cost than
that interventions
non-flash flashing signs here we've
still got the ability to do that within
our
other budgets
and that would be one of the projects
where we potentially could uh if more
funding became available bring that back
into our program
your admit it help if it had words like
sub at the end of that subject to
counsel directions if council chose to
fund that
100 which i can do um then that would be
a matter that would come back first just
adding those words to the at the end of
it
just be clear which one so if so this
funding is not secured these projects
will be moved out three years but still
kept in the writing program just
suggesting that you could add words like
subject to council direction so it would
be better
would come back here and seek council's
conscience a direction on would you
would you be happy with that wedding
yes that's fine
sorry jared i'm just a bit confused with
f
tram road early's road i thought there
was already
rural intersection warning signs on tram
road early's road have they been removed
i'm not aware of any being removed but
they may not be
i'm not sure do can you recall the type
of signs that they are fishy ones okay
are they slightly different
uh i actually just can't answer that
sorry yeah okay that's right because
you know
anyway i just wanted to mention because
i i'm sure i've seen them there um
my second question is
if we're looking at prioritizing in
terms of serious accident and injury
why wouldn't we put up some of the more
important safety improvements at the
intersections on the rural roads as
opposed to
for example the oxford charles up and
drive roundabout which i don't believe
has had a serious injury or accident
so the um that roundabout is not
a part of part of the program so that's
it's the design has been pretty sure yes
yeah um but not the construction
so how much is the design
what i'm trying to get to is
is if we took out the design of that
intersection because we can't afford it
could we bring in
some of the safety improvements to any
of those others or is it because of the
money that you that you've done it that
way
there is some discretion for the council
for some of those projects um for
example in d if you don't want us to
progress with the design then we don't
need to um that's a that that was
something that we could be directed to
do at the annual plan okay
councillor
edmund thank you mr mayor
uh jared just turning to g
which is your new recommendation
um the tuahiwee footpath for example was
approved
in the ltp subject to
waka katohi
funding
which i understand was not available
how have you prioritized that footpath
over other minor safety improvements
that councillor barnett has suggested
um
how have you prioritized this
so that's been uh based on
in terms of a commitment the council has
made
in terms of the council wanting to
prioritize that project
g
um
we're completely open to it's ultimately
your decision which ones you prioritise
so if you would like to
instruct staff to
approach wakakotahi about other projects
other than the tui footpath or the
tanzanian road culvert then that we can
do that so um
the the way we're actually prioritizing
it is putting in front of you today if
you want to make a decision that you
would like to give those priority uh
that's fine if you don't um we can do
that at the time of the annual plan
report
my my understanding from nzta meeting
was that they have approved the
co-funding share with
the tuahiwee footpath that's the
indication we got from nicole and james
when we were there is that correct can
you recall that was the um
indication
uh that would still be subject to their
own processes so i i
i'm pretty sure they said don't hold us
to that uh or words to that effect but
they certainly gave a very strong
indication that that would be one that
they would see would get get through uh
and approved
council even did
i'm just wondering why we would fund the
tuahiwee footpath then ourselves jared
if there may be this ongoing discussion
with the funding agency that they may
fund their half
okay so just to be clear
these would these are subject to the
agency funding their half so
so g would be we would take those two
projects to the agency and say out of
our top-up funding
these are the ones that count towards
the season the recommendation subject to
um approval from rocket
council williams
just following on from council barnett's
question on
um for example the oxford charles upton
round bear why would we be putting
funding into something like that for
design and everything when we've got no
budget whatsoever
and the likelihood of a wee bit of a
time um to do that when the actual
um
constraints of what we do could change
in that area and uh
we've got plans for a roundabout drawn
up plans and all of a sudden there's a
big building that sort of takes away the
sight vision away or
some other
something happens in that area and the
roundabouts not the right type of
thing to put there
what's your question
the question is why would we fund
something
to do some paperwork and draw up now
when in future
the
area could change in direction and that
plans may not be suitable
i can't answer that one specifically
because it is a specific question
that
intersection has got four corners on it
two are existing relatively modern
residential
uh developments and they would not have
the ability to come out into the road
reserve one is a child care center
that's just recently been put up with
car parking there again i
even within their site i can't imagine
a any kind of process that would
uh
build any more up to the boundary and we
do have a road reserve with corner
splays there on the other corner that's
a storm water management area that's
completely within our control so
the only thing that's going to happen to
that intersection in the future is it's
going to get more and more traffic
through it
which if anything
would
increase the demand for a roundabout the
the road that goes up to the north of
there is soon to be connected up to the
um northern part of the arlington area
so it's likely if anything it'll get
more traffic
um and i can't foresee any constraints
that would preclude a roundabout being
constructed and i can't see any other
intersection intervention that would be
we would put in there other than
changing it to a roundabout okay
maybe i probably didn't phrase that
properly and that is a good intersection
probably not a good intersection but why
we'll be doing other
um
site works and um just you know um
in different areas around the uh
waimakariri when we don't know exactly
whether or fit the um
the shoe will fit the right foot um
after we've done it because things do
alter in other areas we're straying into
debate here and i think perhaps that was
well
you're welcome to give the team to a few
worship no look i just sorry i just
can't
i can't answer that because i just don't
quite understand it but i hope you have
a discussion about you offline i think
we've had enough questions here
um i'm i'm going to test the meeting and
move the recommendation as proposed
subject to if with the
subject to council direction and g
which adds um subject to consideration
and draft in the dra um
in the draft annual plan
seconded by council leki
justin speaking to it the really good
questions and the right questions too
definitely to ask through this process
i look we're not at all happy with where
we ended up in the funding round we all
know that we've expressed our views
really strongly at every forum we've had
a meeting
um with the chief executive of nicole
rosie and have certainly expressed that
there are a number of things including
the outside of this the wooden safety
improvements that we have all wanted to
see for some time be properly funded we
raise those really strongly at that
level
it was made really clear to us through
that meeting there are still
opportunities to get projects over the
line
and so
what joanne and
is presenting here in this is
really a best case scenario well
probably the best thing we can do which
is to make sure that these projects
continue to be live so if funding does
come a lot come available we're in the
best position
to
make sure that they're ready to be
considered and funded and co-funded as
the case is
in the
measure of the tuihiwi footpath and
others that was made clear i thought in
the conversation that that would
attract funding support for men's eta
and before the annual planned journey i
would really like
that followed up with nzta and have that
clarified because i think it's a really
important point
um
and the other parts are in here look
this will be a consideration for us as
we consider the annual plan and in the
broad context of all the other bits
and we'll need to carefully consider
whether we wish to add this extra amount
and or not and that's a matter for
council i have sympathy with the points
raised by
the meanings around the safety
improvements
and train road in that area it's uh
certainly we're getting a lot more
crashes through well increased growth
and other things through these things
that we do need to carefully consider
if we got everything in that we wanted
we wouldn't be in this position but
unfortunately we didn't and it's not
that we didn't put our best case forward
because the staff certainly did but we
were told really clearly that
um
projects that it was just as the chief
executive mentioned before that it was
in that it's a national funding program
and unfortunately not all the projects
were funded but there is still scope for
us in these and i think we've still got
to do we've got some work to be to be
doing in this and that's what we're
advised by nzta to continue to do your
work on this and if we're match if we're
match ready then we've got a good
opportunity of potentially getting these
over the line
um
but obviously that'll be our
consideration through the annual plan
how much we wish to
focus on that and i think what's really
important is in the annual plan is that
we see the overall picture where our
increases are looking at with everything
else and that's why i'm going to support
the recommendation this is today council
blackie
subject to council direction added to
recommendation f
n g
was g as well subject to consideration
the draft annual plan you happy with
that
yeah thank you councilman
i'd like to move an amendment please
i'd like to remove oxford road charles
up and drive roundabout from d
and move that to f
and add
a k
which states
asks staff
to investigate and prioritize
the rural intersection safety
listed
in this report
and if possible allocate design funding
that has now become available
can you restate that please
it'd be helpful if you had that and if
you're not that in writing
have you got that here
so we've got
clear on what you want to do with d
but k is uh staff to investigate
rural
investigate and prioritize
and intersection safety improvements as
listed in this report
and to recommend
potential design funding that has now
become available
we're clear with what that reading is
now
tear you've got this recorded an event
what was the last part in design funding
that has now become available from the
design funding that has now become
available
okay so um that's an amendment proposed
the summer prepared to second that
seconded by council award
so councilbar i'll first say that i
absolutely hate having to do this i
think it's a travesty that nzta has not
improved our minor safety program
in a growing district where all of these
projects are absolutely necessary and i
absolutely support them
but when things get tight we have to
prioritize
and people are dying on our rural roads
and facing serious injury we are seeing
many near misses at these rural
intersections and we have to do
something about that
i do understand the necessity for the
roundabout at oxford and charles upham
drive
however the result of a crash there or
of an incident
is likely just to be quite minor
and so i do understand
that
we have to make some hard decisions and
this is a very hard call you will note i
have not removed it i have put it into
the following projects will be delayed
and not progressed until further funding
can be secured it is still in the list
for when nzta gives us a responsible
share of the money
many of the people
who have spoken to in the charles upon
village area
went through the depression in the 1950s
it was a hard time and they had to
prioritize what they could spend money
on they were secondhand clothes
budgets were tight
if we explain that our budget has been
halved by nzta
and we are going to have to delay the
project
to ensure that safety of other residents
in the district is maintained through
improving our rural intersections
i think they will understand this
this is not something we are choosing
i would like all of these projects to be
progressed particularly the townsend
road culvert extension again i think
that's an accident waiting to happen
however we have to be prudent we have to
be frugal and we have to keep our
residents safe
so i urge you to
accept this amendment
to enable us to spend money where it's
most needed
i'm happy to take the
the effect of d
uh and k separately for our members
council ward do you wish to speak
thank you i'm in favour certainly of the
food side
the charles upon
drive
roundabout
but the did you say the lehman's road
not sure about that okay well you can
make your mind up when we come to vote
uh council brian
just a question please how much we're
looking at the charles upper design how
much is that
what's the price tag
um
that's probably in the order something
in that order
so that 50 will buy you what
just you just transfer it off to another
intersection in a different place
um
oh in terms of the saving yeah we could
yes we could put that to
as if this recommendation went through
reprioritize it to some rural
intersection design
okay further speakers
council meetings
i agree with councillor barnett's
statements um
we
unfortunately have to juggle the budget
here we
asked for an amount we got half of it so
we have to to cut a cloth to suit that
budget they're all worthy projects
but to my mind i also agree because
again the faster the speed the bigger
the mess
and
those rural intersections are high speed
big mess
and
i very much like to see them prioritized
so i hope you'll support it
i'm going to support kaye
because i have no problem in that but
i'm not going to support the
re-prioritization of oxford road charles
up and
drive roundabout i
i have long fronted meetings down with
residents it is a big priority in that
area and if you ask residents that live
around that area also i think the
recommendation is quite clear it's
sitting there progressing it to design
stage with the view that hopefully we
can get it over the line it's a really
busy area through there now
we've just it's about to open up
through the
huntington drive the linkage is going to
go through there that's going to improve
the flow that happens through the end
that's going to probably assist in the
case of getting that over the line i
think it would be short-sighted
not to um to do what we're looking what
was originally recommended but i have no
problem with kay
uh councillor williams
yeah um i've got concern of this whole
thing here while this recommendation
so we're just speaking to the amendment
now so we come back to the motion later
so it's the amendment terms it's
controversial motion afterwards okay
any further speakers
well just very briefly i've got similar
to you as to me
frequently down there
and
we need to design
and be prepared to put it in there when
the money becomes available
further speakers so i'm going to put the
amendment so there's two parts to it
um
the first part is that d
uh oxford road be transferred to to f is
that correct councilman
so i'll put that first and then we'll
come to k
i'll put um
that shifting of that into if
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
no
i think we better have a division on
that one thank you
okay councillor atkinson
councillor mealings
councillor stewart's not here councillor
williams
councillor edmund
councillor brian
councillor blackie
councillor barnett
council award
council of duties not here mayor gordon
no
i'm
one two three four five yeses so the
motion's carried so the amendments are
adjusting
are the amendments carried for that is
that correct yes
that was five four four against
so that's again just shifting that all
right so that's
that's that part we come to k
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
declare that um carried so
we're now back to the the amendments now
become form part of the substantive
motion
right fearless speakers do you wish to
speak to motion councillor williams
i do um
i've got big concerns on us adding
budgets to the council's funds at the
moment we're in exactly the same
situation where we've been told the land
transport have pulled funds from some of
these things because they haven't got
the money
well i don't believe our rate powers
have got the money for this as well
without the
land transport funding and
so i got really really good concerns
of not supporting
the recommendation at all because
number one
we will
setting a president there as the land
transport now going to the next round of
things sam will
waimakari council is going to do that
without our support anyway so we don't
need to fund them so much
um that's very
on the tip of my tongue that could
happen
and um
and with our existing rate increase
which is forecast near
we're trying to keep it um under its and
if we keep adding all these bits and
pieces it's going to have a big blowout
and we've um
later on down the track we're going to
have a problem so
it's a real
conundrum to support something like this
because they have funding and and with
covert happening out there people are
going to be struggling paying rates and
what have you and i just can't see
um
a benefit for our rate passes yes i want
all the safety things done and all that
important but i'd like to see a lot more
than just this prioritized and list of
what our roading projects are around the
countryside as well not just
a few of them here this um
i'd like to have says prioritize the
whole lot and see what we can come up
with
you look i don't disagree with council
williams to be honest i but i've got no
problem with voting for this because
this is going through the annual plan
which is the right place to thrash it
out and
if we decide then because he's
he's absolutely right about the fact
that
he have said we don't have the funds
well it's time around this council we
started to say i'm sorry we don't have
the funds
so um that being the case um he's
absolutely right but i the reason i
support this is this going daniel plan
and i'm quite happy
for that to uh
to be discussed there i mean 50 grand
for
roughly for a design we don't know quite
what that is but you know personally all
these safety features that we are
spending billions of dollars on i'd like
to see the billions of dollars going
into retraining drivers because it's
quite frankly not our roads it's our
drivers
that's the problem we've got
and it's the same when you come to speed
limits it's you know it's the drivers
so why aren't we retraining the drivers
not the roads
further speakers
councilwood
well i just um really think it's quite
i'm going to vote for this because i
think we really you we have to put
put it put our
money into safety regardless and i think
that um
there's a big issue with a lot more
people on our rural roads today and
if we don't have the correct signage and
the correct things in place then we're
going to have more deaths on the road
how much do you put
money do you put in in that
on that
losing lives
further speaking which i speak just very
briefly for the record i'm going to vote
in favor of it but
the previous vote was a mistake and it's
going to bite
council redmond
thank you mr mayor i'll be voting in
support of it and i've been persuaded by
the addition of k
because i think safety and
prioritization is very important
and it's not simply a matter of lowering
speed limits that doesn't necessarily
solve the problem
um so i'm hoping this is more meaningful
and i'd like to see us actually
prioritize safety ahead of other nice to
have thanks
for the speakers look i'm the same as
council the brian i'm going to vote in
favor of this made that clear but i am
um really opposed to the the change that
took um oxford road charles from
roundabout out of the uh program and i
know that we will get um submissions on
that so that'll be the opportunity for
residents to let their views be known
but i think it's short-sighted uh doing
that but that's the will of the council
at this point and it'll be open to
submissions at a later stage for
consideration so with that i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carry thank you
right
again this matter will be part of the
annual plan so um do bear that in mind
as you're thinking about it but
entirely in in your hands
council
counseling jarrod
so jared mr cleary please
you could you could potentially become a
counselor if you wished at the next
election jerry that's right last night i
was recommended i should have been a
teacher yeah that's right by the former
marriage
okay look uh thank you this is the um
second report in the series
today now um
this one is uh in regard to our
maintenance operation and
renewal so effectively that's just
maintaining our
road network and renewing any assets on
it it's not any new assets like um the
likes of say new curving channel
footpaths
so
and it's really important that we um
spend the right amount of money or carry
out the right amount of interventions on
our
roading network
if we
under fund
maintenance and new renewals this can
have quite a compounding effect over
time and the um the old saying stitch in
time saves nine definitely applies when
it comes to um road maintenance it's
fair to say
that we in putting the original budget
together really at a staff level
have
did it to the bare minimum
and
certainly we do
try and make the best get the best value
for our
maintenance and operations and renewal
funding
um and our bid we genuinely felt was a
at the correct level so quite
disappointed that
he did not match that
um there's another really important
point here
this
funding happens in a three-year program
so we're already in year one of that
of the
funding program and
um
so
we're really looking for a
for us to take to take that three-year
view and as with
the previous report there is a chance
that more funding may come available
later in this three years
and it's also important to note that if
this
recommendation is approved as it is
that
cost actually gets
would be worn by the council in the
third year of the program so
um it'll be in the
23-24
year that the additional expenditure
gets incurred and that's where it would
have the rating impact
one
it's just something else to bear in mind
certainly part of the decision making as
far as we understand that wakakota he
had when they allocated other councils
proportionately more funding than we
have received
part of the consideration was some other
councils around the country have chosen
to fund over and above
just matching the waku katahi funding
today we
you know i can genuinely say this
council's always played a very straight
bet so we've put up a bid
at the level that we consider as
appropriate
and today
until this year we've actually generally
had that matched
in this case that has not been the case
and
uh thinking further out into the future
um if the council does decide um not to
approve this additional funding um
just you just need to be aware that
that potentially could be a signal to
wakaka tahi that we we accept that
figure and that we can maintain at that
level
um
so and there's something else that's
probably worth noting um
we actually in this in the report we're
saying that the rating impact will be
0.15
increase to the general rate in
in the 23-24 year
um
we actually um
are hoping that we'll we'll do better
than that um and there's the reason for
that is we've actually been able to make
some savings in the
debt
interest and depreciation funding which
we think is actually likely to exceed
the additional cost that we're asking
for
today
and so it's quite likely that when we
get to 22 23 um
we could just still end up even with
this additional expenditure having the
same rating impact that we
had forecast in the ltp
um
so look i'll uh
i think that's probably probably enough
of an introduction i know the council's
had a chance to have a look at this
report previously happy to take any
questions thank you questions
right there's a recommendation some are
prepared to move
counselor brian seconded by councillor
barnett
do you wish to speak counselor brian
counts about it
just really quickly to say that it's
again it's quite sad that we're not
getting any amount of funding for
maintenance and operations and renewals
that we actually need our residents are
going to see a drop in level of service
and we'll have to discuss that very
strongly in the next long-term plan
process if this drop in funding is going
to continue
further speakers
i'm going to support this i don't want
to see our funding fall behind it's
obviously an annual plan consideration
but it's really important that we keep
our maintenance up we know what happens
when you don't
and
then you're playing catch up forever and
a day so
this is one that i do see is very
important
councilwood
if you're the speakers
writer reply counselor brian i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say aye
contrary to clear that carry the jury
the few would pass our thanks on to
joanne and the team
there's a lot of work gone into this and
obviously really
um
complex the funding of nzta in itself is
really complex and i
really appreciate the advice and
guidance that joey and the team are
providing and getting us to this point
so
obviously that'll come back to our
annual plan but if you could pass it i
think so
thank you
you've done a good job stepping as
writing manager today
all right so we're next um
item seven seven point one which is the
chi poi storm water and flooding
improvements
pages 53-60 so we've got rob and jared
is that correct is there any other staff
joining for that report
and kelly kelly and i will be here
kelly come forward to the table um
so rob you're leading the
com the report
uh yes i am thank you
welcome to these chambers that you had a
passion thank you they're looking very
nice aren't they very smart
pass our thanks on to the and people
they've had them push i will continue to
do so
okay thank you
uh so this paper relates to the uh the
shovel ready program of works and you
may recall that you can sort of make
decisions around the prioritization of
works
within the available budget of 18.13
million dollars a couple months ago
the
uh the approach that we took in
advice you on that decision was a
prioritisation of works within the
budget
when we
went back more formally to otakuro as
the agent on behalf of the crown that
they took a different approach in terms
of
what the funding agreement uh implied
and required was around assessing what
is the
the loss of benefits of that change um
we did a lot of work in response to that
about what that
that assessment of benefits
we're saying with the loss of
a macintosh drain pump station out of
that program we still achieve 88 of the
benefits of what is set out in the
funding agreement however i think we
need to be realistic that and we all
knew this at the time
that the
uh
macintosh drain pump station not been in
the in the program was a material change
to the um and the material loss of what
we all hope to achieve out of the
program
the
uh
what also we didn't consider at the time
and this is an error on our part and we
didn't catch this that there is a dc
contribution which is funding part of
the macintosh drain pump station works
that is inherent in the 18.13 million
dollar budget so there is remains a
commitment towards the pump station by
council regardless and there's i think
six hundred thousand dollars um being uh
accrued in that account um
from dc so
uh
what we have what i think was discussed
either way um
in a briefing with you but uh and on on
on the basis of that briefing we went
towards hakuro and said well we'd like
to propose a different type of change
that
the macintosh trained pump station be
done in the 2023 financial year
and we deliver the 18.13 million dollars
worth of work by september next year
which is in accordance with the funding
agreement
plus some minor changes around some of
the smaller items of work which are more
asset management based
and so that's what this
paper proposes is that that as part of
the draft annual plan that you signal
now to include uh the macintosh drain
pump station in the
2023 financial year
and that probably summarises
the contents of the paper
thanks rob any of the other staff pushed
ahead
no i think rob's covered it off pretty
well
just just the only point to note under
recommendation um
i believe it is it talks about we've
effectively got the beach road pump
station which is subject to the
acquisition or partial acquisition of
213 beach road
and if we if that is delayed or if we're
not successful with that then we'll be
looking at swapping in the macintosh
drain pump station in advance and that
is something that we've signaled in the
proposed
change to otakuro and the crown as well
thank you
any questions of colleagues council
meetings
on that kelly um so how was that
received whenever you signal to that
change
uh
so otakuro have noted it and the paper
going up to the crown i believe goes to
ministers tomorrow
that considering it tomorrow as we
understand or the or thursday i think um
and so we'll expect a response
shortly after then so they otakura have
recommended that
our proposal to ministers
okay
thank you for the questions we've got a
recommendation some prepare to move
council blacky's seconded by council
atkinson
would you like to speak counsel back
to say another report that we're
recommending we're not happy about but
that's been the tenor of the afternoon
hasn't it
thank you uh council reckons and
further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clearly carrot okay
thank you
thanks rob uh we're now at item 8.1 the
adoption of the annual report for the
year ended 30th of june mr millwood
good afternoon
hopefully you'll be happy with this
report
because it's got some good results in
there
so this is to adopt the annual report in
its um
auditor's opinion
for the year ended june 2021
there's a couple of bigger movements in
the annual report this year
namely the six million dollar
devaluation of some of the mixed
business use land in the red zone
and nine four nine point four million
dollars worth of uh entry swap swaps on
our
that we put in place for our debt
uh so contrary to previous years where
swaps went
uh down and we had to record losses
uh this year with the movement and the
interest rates which are going to
continue and will continue to make gains
on them
they're really just paper figures
that we've got to recognize in
accounting terms in our books
we've also received quite a bit of
shovel ready and stimulus funding so
that's shown in and that's what's made
that balance of the 13.2 million
variance on our surplus
we don't really make a surplus we break
our
accounts even
it was a good year for a capital work so
the first time since prior to the
earthquakes uh
we completed over 90 percent of our
capital works
and that will put us in good stead when
uh standard poor's look at our credit
rating later on
uh in the new year
and if you take the
non-financial performance measures uh in
the five percent within five percent of
the target we're up near 90 for those as
well so we had a pretty good year
considering we're affected by covet
19.
so
i've done a summary of some of the
significant movements on 4.2 of the
annual
of the report
just in this afternoon you would have
seen a copy of the
auditor's
opinion that's been put into diligent so
it's probably the first
download that you'll see there
and that's for both our annual report
and the summary report
and when the council adopt this paper
it needs to recognize in those
recommendations that the order's opinion
has also been adopted within that annual
report so other than that
i just want to recognize helene street
she's the project manager for it
and she
rounds up all the staff each year and
and the staff have been marvelous this
year um
and the auditors have commented on that
um we had a new audit director this year
and whenever we get a new audit director
which usually happens every six years
but we it happened earlier this year
during because of covert
they usually do a lot more testing and
that's what we experienced this year
so
happy for any questions
thank you i might just ge if we might
just have a pause there and let
colleagues go and then just have a look
at the
um report the um author's opinion yeah
78.1 that's right um i probably should
note that there's a it's an unmodified
opinion so that's a
clean and clear report of any
qualifications so
nothing bad in there at all they have
made a comment around three quarters
which removes just under three quarter
just under a third of our business with
that mandated decision the government
made
within post balance events we've put a
note in here that we have challenged
that legally and we've also written a
letter to the minister to the prime
minister
so that's basically commented and i
think some note 30 of the annual reports
so it's
it's well documented
i'll give i'll give you all five 10
minutes just have a read it so 10
minutes just have a read over there you
should be aware of what's there so
it's in diligent 8.1 so we just have a
brief adjournment while members just uh
have a chance to read over that
[Music]
so questions for mr milwaukee
well i'd like to move the recommend if
there's no questions move the
recommendation is there someone prepared
to second council award
um
jeff an outstanding piece of work as
always from you and your team
and just acknowledge all the work that's
gone into
preparing our annual
report
it's kind of i always find this an
interesting exercise when we go through
an annual plan but we've then got to
present a different report but anyway
that's complying with legislation and
what we're required to do um
couldn't be um more pleased of where
we're at
in terms of this position and unmodified
reporters uh when i know that there's
other councils around the country that's
struggling to even get there
long-term plans audited um really speaks
to the uh
the capacity and the ability of our
staff you lead so ably by yourself and
acknowledge elaine for her efforts
also i had the privilege of meeting the
auditor with you not that long ago and
she's a new auditor
and
the questions and her depth of
understanding was i was very impressed
with actually
she'd certainly done their homework on
their organisation and the things that
auditors find there were a range of
things that they go through just
demonstrate that they do look very
carefully at our organisation and their
performance they certainly were
interested in our position around the
legal measure and felt that that did
need to be recorded because it's
obviously a risk for the council
and taking it on um and felt that it
needed to be reported they weren't
concerned but they had certainly done
their homework on that but look um jeff
you and the team thank you very very
much
um you're all highly valued for what you
do and we do appreciate it it's
it leads to the financial the financial
performance of this council was always
well regarded it's not something we take
for granted and we appreciate your
leadership and stewardship in this area
council
thank you i just want to reiterate a big
thank you to jeff
and the whole team and also all the
staff because um
they all
have prudent controls over their budgets
and really have worked really hard and
really extreme conditions covered but
also the expectations of of our rate
payers uh where we're in tremendous
growth and yet trying to keep the rates
down but i have to say that our growth
has probably been our best asset so that
it enables us to have
um some um excesses or or um some
some um
uh surpluses which we might not have we
didn't have the growth that we have in
this district we must never forget that
we need to look after the growth which
will enable us to do more for less
thanks joan any further speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thanks
jeff
so we're now at 8.2 which is the
submission to mb on three waters
economic regulator
juror and libby that's probably one of
the rare things that we support
potentially of the
work the government's doing in three
waters
uh
thank you so the purpose of this report
is to
ask
council
effectively to delegate to approve the
submission as it stands
and to delegate to the chief
executive to end the mayor to make
changes to those that
submission so
uh you'll recall there's really three
parts to the water reform that's
currently underway
one is the regulations which is
effectively the
drinking water standards
the other part is the regulator so
there's two regulators involved here one
is the tomato roi the
water quality regulator that's already
been stood up and has a chief executive
and as a fit as operational
and this
second part to that regulation is the
economic regulation so
mb have put out
a discussion this discussion
document um and we've uh we've started
to put together a response that we've
got until the 20th of december to submit
that
um
this document is effectively the first
draft of one that has is also going to
the merrell forum so we agreed to hold
the pen as a starting point on that
and we are getting further feedback from
other councils
including environment canterbury on
the this document so it will
the one that you see today
won't be exactly the same as the one
that finally gets submitted
subject to approving these
this recommendation of course
um the it's probably just a few
reflections on it the document itself um
is
pretty uh
much it looks very much like something
that's been taken um
as
from the electricity or
telecommunications sector and there's a
lot of language in it that doesn't
really align with the way local
government provides three water services
things like references to the consumer
without
much if any reference to communities
or in councils also so councils as both
the shareholders of the
water services entities
and also as councils as community
representatives so that's certainly
something that
we'll be making quite clear in our
submission
that needs to be recognized
and also i think when you think about
the three water services the most
challenging one for economic regulation
is going to be storm water and we
believe
that a lot of the points that we'll be
making will hopefully make that fit a
lot better
so there's two parts to it there's the
economic regulation which basically
talks about how much money the entities
can spend and um
in
undertaking their work and how much they
can charge people and then there's
consumer protection so
we're um proposing uh in general to
support um
the regulation and the consumer
protection we see them both as being
very important and
a large reason for that is the size
scale and the monopoly position that
these water entities will be in
we think it's really important that they
are subject to
economic regulation and consumer
protection probably one of the other
things is we do
recommend quite a phasing phased
approach because both the entities and
the
and the regulator will have to learn
their way in this space to an
extent and there'll be quite a lot of
disclosure involved
the other point is
regardless of what happens in terms of
the reform
whether
three waters does actually end up
remaining with councils and transfers
into the entity we do see benefit in
having the
economic regulation and consumer
protection
but i would say very much um it's more
important if it was to go into the big
entities because a lot of the
protections people currently get
um through councils would be lost and
that's the source of the ability to
interface directly with their elected
members and have direct them put into
things like annual plans
so there's probably a enough from me
where libby and i are both happy to take
any questions because she had anything
libby
see any questions just start with
castanya's doing some work on behalf of
the uh
i guess the opposition um to put the
right word uh come up with the correct
term which we should be able to talk
about next week
um but castalia is doing some work on
that at the moment have we had any
conversation with him to make sure that
our submissions aligning
yeah
uh no but we certainly can do that's
quite uh we're quite gonna do that yeah
thank you and i i guess it's being
careful about how we phrase our support
for this it's not supporting three
waters reform but it's
um it's the council's submission but
it's
um supporting the regulation aspect and
as a as it pertains so it's getting that
wording balance right in there jared
is there any other comments
obviously it'll become to terry jones
sort of comments i mean questions
questions yes
how are we going to make sure
that um we make it in no uncertain terms
that
we do not want to be part of a any any
of the four entities
and that we
we totally disagree with handing over
our assets to these entities our
ratepayers assets
um we can include
words to that effect uh at the front end
of the submission
yes i think that's some it's important
and that was following from the question
i raised before which is just getting
that balancing right but obviously the
chief executive and myself if council
agrees the recommendation
will be signing off and we'll ensure
that that reading is
where we
know the council's viewers
any other questions
but this is a work in progress i know
you haven't had long to do it
um so you know you've made a really good
start of it so thank you
all right um some are prepared to move
move to councillor williams seconded by
uh councillor edmund do you wish to
speak council williams
and i just think we need to make sure
their views are known um about the three
waters in it
council um
redmond
further quick further um
further points
i'll put the recommend do you wish to
try the reply no
nothing to respond to really and she was
she'll respond to yourself um i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thanks
libby and jerry
right next is 8.3 which is the dixon
road cemetery land acquisition
chris
just give me one second
thank you
so this report identifies the process
that we've been through to
um get to a stage where we are seeking
delegation from
uh council to the chief executive myself
to um follow the public works act to
acquire 12 hectares of land at dickson's
cones road from coaliston
farms
limited
we've been working with them for a
number of years and we've seen council
a report previously which allowed staff
the mandate to go and negotiate with
coalition farms
there are
a number of conditions which coalescent
farms would like to
have attached to the salem purchase
agreement
including any future reserve development
contributions
being waived
how they would like to lease the land
back they would like a section of the
proposed symmetry to be used for
their family burial
those are the main conditions when
looking at um
the proposal staff believed and have
recommended that uh we do enter into the
salem pitch screen with those conditions
um
the symmetry that we have in ranger at
the moment has got
around about 30 years left depending on
the split between ash internment and
burying of bodies
um
however that time will go past very
quickly and acquiring land for
cemeteries
close to
residential areas
is really really hard
not many people want asymmetry right
next to where they live
we are
lucky in this case that
three sides of the property that we're
talking about are still owned by
coalition farms we i have personally
been out
and met with a resident on the other
side of the property who was at first
[Music]
not
in favor but um after conversations
around the buffer planting that would uh
that's identified on the concept plan
um what is now i'm happy that it would
go ahead as long as some of that buffer
planting would be done pre uh prior to
people being buried um 30 years away
we've identified in the report that we'd
likely come to the council with a later
long-term plan to look at
funding to get some of that buffer
planting done in an early stage which
would likely be
a mixture of native native and exotic
planting
i'm happy to take any questions
we have received a resource consumed
from environment canterbury which has
said that the land is appropriate
for asymmetry um that we had to modify
the concert plan a little bit
because we have to have areas where
the water table is three metres and
below and some were slightly above that
so we had to modify what we were doing
with ashes going into those wetter areas
at the bottom of the terrace and
burials
going into other areas but he can have
put some conditions in place the
conditions are
pretty limited and we're accepting of
those conditions so um that's good
thank you
thanks chris any questions
uh there's a recommendation
moved to council brian secretary council
award council very briefly future
proofing well done to all concerned
council award
just i support this it's a very generous
donation from the robertson family the
robertsons approached me in the early
stages around this and connected with
staff chris you and the team have done
an excellent job getting it to this
point and
i think it's certainly certainly a
no-brainer as far as i'm concerned and
we've had a briefing on this so good
work and be great to get this concluded
uh further speakers
write a reply counselor brian
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thanks
chris
we're now at 8.4 so um
it's the adoption dangerous and affected
and sanitary buildings policy it's a
recommendation from the hearing panel so
um gina
and
who else are you coming forward as well
warren and greg if he wishes to as well
the family is welcome to come to the
table
family's always welcome at the table
especially greg
good to see you greg
i see you haven't got that new shirt we
were talking about the other day
oh sorry warren could you switch on your
microphone please thank you
good afternoon councillors um today
we've got a uh policy on dangerous
affected and sanitary buildings 2021
which we'd like to uh present to you
this has been through the um
the hearing and deliberation meeting on
the 14th of october
and the rev a recommendation is made the
council would adopt this policy
can i take it that this policy has been
read by everybody yep and i'll open up
for any questions
thank you before i open to questions
any panel members wish to any uh comment
council redmond i'll see you with a
chair and cuts the barnett you only
anything you wish to add
uh not particularly mr mayor i think it
was
it's a small area of policy but quite an
important one
and the change to the existing policy
was to introduce an affected building
criteria
and an affected building is a building
next to a
dangerous or unsanitary building
so um we had a good discussion i think
we talked about the need for this to be
noted on limbs
in case you're buying a property next to
a dangerous or insanity building
we made a number of amendments and
added a cost provision
so
all in all i think it's a good result
and thanks to the team for their efforts
thank you councilman do you wish to
anything
okay so questions any questions
we come to the recommendation some
prepared to move counselor redmond
seconded by
council barnett
do you wish to speak
i think i've already spoken mr mayor but
i have pleasure in recommending this for
adoption thank you
council about it
thank you
any further speakers just thank the
panel members for their effort they've
done a really good job bringing this
together along with our staff it's a
very
important
policies so it's good to have this
reviewed and obviously hopefully
approved today so
the new policy
write a reply accounts redmond i'll put
that all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that kerry thanks team
thank you
right 8.5
district parking strategy for adoption
vanessa
more of the family coming up hi simon
welcome
good afternoon councillors and mr mayor
uh this purpose of this report is to
seek approval from council for the
adoption of the district parking
strategy so you'll note we just
completed a month-long public
consultation process from 18 october to
14 november
and there are no changes to the strategy
as a result of that feedback so you'll
note we had five or six submitters and
there were no changes
it's important to get the strategy
adopted today because the minimum
parking requirements are coming out of
the operative district plan by february
2022 so this document does provide some
guidance to staff as to how we'll manage
parking going forward so i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you uh councillor
i guess there's really one question and
that is we get so many complaints about
parking
why have we only received so few
submissions
i'm not too sure on that actually we did
have quite a bit uh quite a reach with
it um we opened it up on our public
platforms i think because it's such a
high level
strategy that maybe people just didn't
engage with it so much it wasn't like
our survey that we did earlier in the
year which was specifically around
parking issues in the district so that
could be why
so will there be an opportunity now that
they've got the strategy if we adopt it
for people then to input on a more local
level
i guess we will do that more on specific
issues that come up in the future if
there's a particular area of concern
if we look at say our anger or parking
management plans or our kaiapoi town
centre parking management plans they
will address specific issues in the town
centres and how we resolve those going
forward and i would imagine that we
would probably look at more community
feedback in association with those
issues on a specific nature
any further questions
series of recommendations some prepared
to move
moved council awards second goodbye oh
i've seconded it
um sorry i didn't see it counselor you
can second it if you like you're on your
uh
we go council award
no i i just want to say
well done you're a great team we're so
pleased to have you doing all the work
that you do for us
thank you
council meetings
just like to congratulate you for coming
up with a coherent strategy given the
feedback is always so
contradictory that we get
we want more parking but we want more
space for people but we want
more active transport but we want to
take our cars to it
so um well done for sorting all of that
out
thank you i'm supportive um
excellent work as always vanessa
well done
if is the interesting part of the
recommendation which is the disability
parking provision that will be addressed
as part of the
accessibility strategy review next year
and that's the one i'm i think there'll
be a lot of interest in because it's one
i get a lot of feedback about the lack
of
in some people's view with those
particularly around kaiapoi i get a bit
of feedback down there and those that
want to be able to park immediately out
in front of shops
and so i'm sure that's something we will
get a lot of feedback on next year but
i'm fully supportive of this one here
and thanks for the work
right of reply
no i'll put the recommendation all those
in favor please say hi
contrary to clear that carry thank you
right 8.6 non-financial performance
measures helene
great to see you
could you use your mic there thanks
thank you so yep good afternoon mr
council um firstly apologize apologies
for this report not getting to order the
musk last month it was a
small hiccup there um so this is the
quarter one report for the 20 20 21 22
financial year as you'll see we're now
in the new format using opel3 software
so hopefully it's been a bit more
presentable and a bit easier to
understand
thank you many questions questions of
colleagues
any questions
this is there's a recommendation someone
appeared to move
council redmond's got his hand up i'm
sure
followed by councillor atkinson
do you wish to speak council ethan
i'll put this on and say no mr man thank
you any further speakers
well i'm just going to say thanks helene
great piece of work and it's very much
appreciated so
um
i don't think there's any other speakers
no need for right of reply messy wishes
to accounts for edmund i'll put that all
those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear it carried thanks
elaine thank you
um
conflicts of interest reaches to 8.70
i take the report of red mist mayor
ok any questions from colleagues
moved by councillor atkinson seconded by
councillor brian do you wish to speak
council atkinson council lebron
i'll put the recommender and this is
further speakers i put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear it carried that's
probably your quickest report to us
sarah
we take it that there's no changes
next is 8.8 which is
tab 15 elected member expense policy
update thank you sarah this is just a
minor change
based on feedback from the remuneration
authority
and it relates to the sections of 5.3
and 5.4
of the hearings and it's just spelling
out
that the
funding of that is over and above the
elected member
remuneration pool
of funds
so
there's no technical change it's just um
clarification as requested by the
authority
thanks sarah any questions
so we've got a recommendation some
prepared to move moved by council ryan
seconded councillor blackie
uh do you wish to speak
any other speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor aye
contrary to clear that carrot thanks
sarah thank you very much
right
nine point one through two
which is a big series here ellie you're
you're in uh stepping in today uh with
jared thank you thank you stop stepping
in
okay thank you council brian
all right
ellie um and jared thank you and um
if you want to take us through these
should be pretty well understood by
members because it's been to the boards
it's been to council we've had lots of
uh
workshops about these and briefings and
it's been to all the community boards
and out to consultations so
it's a pretty extensive process
ellie
so good afternoon everyone all of these
reports that you've just heard have been
through the community boards and council
has been briefed prior to this meeting
on the process that we use to set speed
limits
these reports detail the results of
three-week speed limit consultation
across september and october and
subsequent recommendations made to the
boards
overall 297 submitters provided feedback
and we also sought feedback from key
stakeholders like the new zealand police
wakakotahi and various other
organisations
it should be noted that the main street
oxford changes will be subject to
council consideration of the budget as
part of the annual planned deliberations
and the cass road change through the
township will need to be made in
conjunction with planned speed calming
measures
all new speed limits implemented will be
subject to speed counts within the six
months of implementation did anything to
addre
uh no i think the um we've had quite a
lot of engagement with elected members
on these as they've made their progress
but we're both happy to take any
questions
thank you um just first off i think um
the table is discussed earlier the table
and
um
table one needs an adjustment next
annual plan and the same and the wording
it should be
should be clear about what in your plane
tier did you follow that up
okay so basically it says in there it
talks about the next annual plan
it should be um as part of so if the d
should reflect as part of um the
uh 22 23 and your plan i think to be
correct
um
and the same in the table
just makes the world otherwise which
next annual plan is that is this one or
is it the one after no that's correct
yeah okay this is to tidy that up
questions
count savannah
um
jared the 40k speed limit through the
oxford township
how likely are we to get any funding for
that from nzta
very unlikely to get any that would be
most likely would be entirely funded by
a council if we were to
adopt that
and
when you look at major arterial roads
through the country that have townships
what is the normal recommended speed
ship or speed
limit on those townships
in general
most
roads that have a
major arterial through them and in most
instances
50 although a lot of town centres
where it's not necessarily the major
through route might have a reduced speed
limit
and in some of those circumstances there
would be a designated
alternate route for heavy vehicles and
traffic
but it's a very general very general
answer to a very general question thank
you just my final question is what
consultation has been done with
transport operators federated farmers
and other road users
about the proposed 40k speed limit
through oxford township
so we put this out to the
i think it's rfit the road transport
association and the trucking association
and
another heavy vehicle association as
well
one of them provided feedback they did
send it out to their members but as part
of the rule they don't have to
send in feedback so we have spoken to
them about it and there were no concerns
picked up by them with the speed limit
through oxford
you further questioned sir councillor
blacky
sorry this question's a bit late i
talked to joanne about it months ago and
then i forgot um hayward's road where it
joins tram road is still 70. we've
changed every other 70 we've got to
something to 60 or 80 or whichever way
we've gone why have we left that 170
dead you haven't no in haywards road or
[Laughter]
good question um so initially when we
did this process we had a lot of roads
that we chopped back
um we wanted to focus on key areas where
we could make implement these changes
easily
and so we figured that doing things next
to near kaiapoy through a hoka in that
lot were easier to get across the line
in this stage however as part of the new
setting a speed limit rule
we are going to have to set potentially
permanent speed limits outside rural
schools and that will make that whole
process easier with dropping the rest of
the speed limit in that zone
thank you for the questions
just to clarify um
with mill row with several mill roads in
our district can you just clarify on the
table that says oxford roads
the mill road 100k zone that you're
talking about
so
so the
the mill road zone that we're talking
about is from
main street up to bush road
but the western section of bush road so
it's 100 kilometers per hour zone
through there
yes smell right oxford yeah
thank you for the well we suggest that
we actually modify the resolution to
just reflect that so we're
clear on that so which where's that just
so just so we're clear on that now in
table two
um another row looks about the third uh
line from the bottom there yes just add
that in brackets that um
a section that was just described
so have you got that here
yep so
we're clear on that okay um
yes
table two
proposed speed limit on oxford road so
mill road can we just clarify that again
please
purposes clarity yeah absolutely so mill
road is in oxford from main street
up to the western section of bush road
that's a no end road essentially
okay
everyone's clear on that
council redmond
thank you mr mia
shortly prior to this meeting we had an
education session on the setting of
speed limits
um if we apply those criteria to main
street oxford what would the answer be
50 kilometers an hour
thank you very much
thank you um so we've got a rigged
series of recommendations here council
meetings
moving as is with those changes to
mill road
and the changes to 2022 23 and your plan
is that moving
yes
um
and whilst i understand some of the
questions around the table here with
regard to main road okay so just just
make sure you've got a second and then
you're welcome to speak the secondary
counselor blacky would you like to speak
all right so well whilst i do understand
just where some of the questions might
be coming from on main street oxford
um the reason for this being put in here
is because we were under a concerted
effort lobbied by the community who very
very much wanted 40. they would have
taken 30 if they could get it
um
it's probably been the hottest issue
that anybody has ever turned up to any
of our community board meetings and it
was put onto the schedule even though it
wasn't actually scheduled for review it
was put on here because of the
community's great desire to see it there
and and of course we will then go back
to them during the annual plan and say
okay here it is are you willing to pay
for it
but
i do hope that
you will respect the community board's
decision to
respect the the will of the people who
asked to put it there in the first place
and allow it to go forward
in this
form and
support the
motion as put
thank you council meetings council
blacky
further speakers i'm i'm going to
support it as is um and entirely for the
reasons counts the meetings is put that
was a
very
strong
um view come through from
members of the community i'm not going
to say all members of the community now
is the time to test whether that's
something that's broadly supported and
given the likely cost implications it's
not binding the council this is part of
an annual plan process and it gives
those individuals who also submitted
strongly during our long-term plan the
opportunity to have that voice that's
the basis in which i support this i have
my reservations about the amount
definitely do but would like to hear the
community's view before coming to a
final decision
making main street 50 kilometers per
hour is the change
main street main street oxford urban
area to remain at 50 kilometers per hour
is there a seconder
seconded
well i'm allowed to i'm happy to for
that to be tested it's just tested and
uh council redmond is seconding it
i i fully understand why we've had so
many submissions about oxford um
it's a busy area it's a tourist town
there's a lot of heavy traffic going
through it
and um but 50 kilometers an hour is
designated nationwide as a safe speed to
go through a township
and
it would be inconsistent of us to put
the speed down to 40 kilometers per hour
which is outside nzta guidelines
um
we have been lobbying in cusp for years
to go down to 50 kilometers an hour
instead of 60 kilometers an hour and the
cast village is an equally busy stretch
of road
um and now the council's saying that
maybe we can get to 50
but
if we were going to put oxford down to
40 then cast village is exactly the same
situation and should be 40.
and we're not even proposing that
i understand there's some very
passionate individuals and i do
understand their reasons but we have to
look at common sense
we have to look at the fact it's going
to cost this council 450 000
to reduce a speed on an arterial road
that's important to our district
for no real major benefit
i have not seen
that there is particular danger in this
stretch of this country town as opposed
to any other country town in new zealand
as opposed to cust as opposed to sefton
the sefton pub is quite busy at times
and that's actually 60 kilometers an
hour
so for us to put something through at 40
kilometers an hour to be considered as
part of the next general plan when we're
trying to save money and nzta are not
going to support us for the 450 000 or
any subsidy
we're doing this on a political basis
whereas we need to do it on a common
sense and prudent financial basis
i respect the wishes of all our
community but not everyone can get what
they ask for
it's just not possible for us to go
outside the guidelines all the time if
it's going to cost our rate payers extra
so i urge you to support keeping it 50
kilometers now being brave sending a
signal to our residents that we do
understand we listened but unfortunately
the criteria does not match and we do
not have the funding for this
um
i had uh so i'll come together so the
second day was councillor edmund do you
wish to speak
yes i do thank you mr mayor
i think the question i ask really
answered
the question in my mind
under the nzta guidelines
and rules and we had a detailed
education session prior to this meeting
um
we're going below the recommended speed
which is 50 kilometers per hour to come
up with 40.
it it's not based on science if the nzta
guidelines are scientific
the cost of implementing it is excessive
and really main street
is not called main street for nothing it
is a main street through a rural town
and i don't support
40 kilometers i realize there will be a
section of the community who said they
can't cross main street then maybe we
look at some other form of
pedestrian crossing to enable them to do
so which would be far less expensive
than reducing the speed
limit over the whole length of their
particular stretch
so
i support the amendment
you're the speakers council at concern
yeah look i support uh for exactly the
reasons that have been spoken to the
amendment um
i don't support this in total
i may just speak to that afterwards but
you already know my feelings on this
it's quite interesting watching an
advertising campaign on television that
talks about common sense
council of only just talked about common
sense
interestingly i've probably been to
17 i counted up
um
[Music]
sight safe
qualifications that i have
and uh every time i go there there are
people talking about common sense under
the health and safety act of new zealand
common sense is not a denominator at all
because everybody's common sense is
different
yet here we are in a
safety aspect trying to change
speed limits suggesting that we should
use common sense when the government
actually tells us and they're teaching
so that there is no such thing as common
sense when you're looking at these
things so i find that rather interesting
that that's why we're looking at this
but i believe that 40 k's
sorry 50k through the the main streets
is absolutely perfect we look at kai poi
26 k's is the average speed
if we're looking at lowering the speed
level i mean you know people don't even
do it most of the time yes there are
people who speed through these places i
have no no doubt about that but
certainly in oxford i've spent many
times up there now i do not live there
many times up there and watched people
cross the road and sometimes people go
through there pretty quick and in fact
ninety percent of the time it's the
people who live in oxford that speed
through the main street
further speakers uh look i'm not going
to support the amendment um i i this has
been through our community board and
through that process so i support it
coming going back out i'm look whatever
happens i'm not going to lose sleep
about it certainly the budget aspect of
it i do have really strong concerns
about but i really was quite prepared to
aim prepared to hear this um
discussed through our annual planning
process and hear the views about why the
community i don't have a problem in that
we're going to get submissions on it
we've had them every year this was the
reason for putting it out and to let our
community know if it does go to that
what the cost implications would be for
doing so
i don't you know there's been some views
of at board level
of how what far and wide this was
understood out there
in the submission process so that's why
i was prepared i'm prepared to
support that going out there with the
view but
if it did come back
you know that would be a matter of
balancing our consideration of of budget
and i i'm not overly persuaded
on the budget sense at this point in
time but i am prepared to hear what the
community has to say on it
and
always support our community generally
try and support our community boards
when they come back here with um
recommendations
further speakers
i'll put the i'll put the amendment
um
those in favor please say aye
those against no
so i think it's carriage
oh i don't think what at least you
really want it yeah okay why not
brian's not here council blackie
councillor barnett
council award
yes
councilman do you mean gordon
no
so that's carried
six two
okay so the amendment now becomes the uh
uh the motion
for the speakers to the rest of the
amendment
so what was that jane
did you have something you want to say
okay
okay do you wish to speak to him no any
further speakers to the uh
recommendation
i'll put the so um before i do so do you
wish to exercise rather apply cancer
meetings
whilst i'm not going to die in a ditch
over this um
it is the will of the community of
oxford and the community board
and therefore i would be quite remiss to
go against that and therefore i voted
the way i did
thank you i'll put the
put the recommendation those in favor
please say aye
declare that kerry
oh
sorry hold on i'll just quickly do it
again so all those in favor please say
aye
contrary no no and there's two votes you
wish both wish them recorded
so i declare that carried
all right um
and
we're at 9.2 now
hopefully less controversial
and again this has been through the
process so we're happy to take them as
read
i think so well why don't is there
anyone opposed to what is recommended in
the
the coming ones
so why don't we just well look i'm gonna
take them first
okay well
9.2 um
no
no they're individual because they're
individual
so 9.2
which is what end safety in the summer
prepared to move is there any questions
some prepare to move the recommendation
moved council barnett seconded council
redmond do you wish to speak
any further speakers i'll put that all
those in fact
oh yes
as the second or i was just going to
comment that these speed limits were
supported by the community board
they're fairly sensible and i'm
accordingly supporting them
okay write a reply i'll put that and
this is only for the speakers put that
all those in favor aye
contrary to clear that carried no
no oh both knows okay all right okay is
it is that standard through the way
through here
uh well i'm just
yeah just i'm not trying to jump the gun
just trying to be efficient to get
through
9.3 which is uh recommendations for
speed limits through ring euro
do you wish did you have some questions
counts about it
okay i was just checking because you
said you're about rengura okay so um
do you so there's a recommendation
you're going to move council williams
someone prepared to move well i'll move
it
seconded council award um anyone wish
just look
it's a it's straightforward it's been
through an exercise that's been endorsed
by the community board and been out to
the community
i think it makes it makes makes sense
sorry
makes makes sense okay just acknowledge
ally and the work that you've done uh um
through this exercise it's been
extensive and
all the workshops with us it applies for
all so thank you for all your work in
the space
um the second uh do you wish to speak
do you wish to speak counselor williams
yep
i just like reported why i'm saying no
to these speed reductions
on mess like this i think it's a land
transport new zealand's um
they should be the ones um enforcing
this here we're we're bringing roads
down to speeds of 80ks when we've
already done surveys and the people are
only doing 82 kilometers on these roads
now so we're spending a lot of money
for
bringing some roads down and on mess
like this i'm not a favor because if you
had some of these roads yes they've got
to come down and speed i believe
some of them know they shouldn't come
down so
on mess
i think we're doing a a disservice to
our community because some of these
roads look like
they still should be 100k roads and
it's it's doing a disservice unless we
can actually
make these roads look like they should
be 80k roads and um
yeah and
you know these roads people aren't
speeding on them now because if we've
got genuine surveys here from our staff
and they're saying that traveling will
i'll go mount thomas road for example
we want to bring that down to 80 uk's
well the people are only driving the
average time of 82 kilometers an hour
now so what is the point of us spending
all this money
doing this
when that six speeds are doing now so i
just can't fathom it out and um you know
i think it's a land transport
scenario they should be enforcing and
telling us because that's basically what
i understand they're twisting our arms
to bring it all down to this um the
recommendations so that's why i can't
support these
recommendations
any further speakers counselor barnes
yes i'm i'm really reluctant to go
against the recommendations of my board
and generally uh 99 of the time i
support community board recommendations
um but unfortunately ranga ashley is a
board of two halves it's it's 80
urban 20 rural so
i'm the rural voice one of the rural
voices on that that board and most of
these roads are roads that we have to
travel all the time
and they're quite comfortable a lot of
them at 100k if you drive sensibly
many of these i'm happy that they go
down but like um councillor williams i
think this mess picking out of roads to
try and
match them all up into a circle
doesn't reflect the condition of the
road and if we're going to make these
speed limits enforceable um and not
sort of
present a road that looks like a rural
road but you're forcing a lower speed
limit then we need to put conditions in
place that we can actually make it look
like that but unfortunately we have got
no budget from nzta to do so so i would
like to see the responsibility for lower
speed limits to go back to nzta i think
that they need to say that if a road is
going to be a non-rural road and lower
than 100k
it needs to have some conditions on it
that make it actually look like it
should be traveled at a lower speed
limit
my probably my prime example of all of
these is we're trying to encourage
people to go around rangiora to stop the
congestion that's in europe and yet
we're dropping down fernside road um in
in those areas to 80 k's when that's a
predominantly rural road that we have
not had the money to fix up and make it
a decent road
and it is quite narrow but you can't
blame the road for the fact that we
haven't made it um easy to travel as a
rural side road of ringura
so
my conjecture here is that i have to
vote against this for all rural
residents who need to use these roads to
get to their properties
who
see them as rural roads
and don't want to be paying speed fines
for doing 90 kilometers on these roads
when actually it's a perfectly safe
speed to travel if you drive responsibly
so i am really really reluctantly not
supporting this report i respect my
board members and their reasons for
saying about safety but you don't make
safety just by putting up a sign
you make safety by changing the
condition of the road
and making it easier for people to
respect the road conditions
further speakers i have counselling
concerned followed by council redmond
yeah look i just i just want to back
that and put my case on the table i've
always vocated it against these this is
nanny state stuff
this is making sure that we can't get
anyone to do what they need to do or
what they want to do we make sure that
we have to control what they do
river road is the perfect example for me
i voted for that to go to 50k
advised against by our staff strongly
because it was a rural setting of a road
and what did we do we put it at 50 k's
and i think if you asked council lebron
he probably issues more tickets down
there than he does anywhere in the in
the
in the district no one takes any notice
of it markston road there's another one
60k
i don't think in the last six months
i've traveled down that road at 60k
once
it's always 70 or 80 k why because it's
in a rural setting
because the road doesn't can fit the
sign
people just don't take notice of it
train the damn driver
cut this nanny state out where we have
to tell people to to do these things at
this time cut that out and actually put
in there some safety rules that will
work
a red sign does not do it
in fact orange lights don't do it
because people seem to think that orange
is nearly green
it's the same thing we need to make sure
that we put the driver training in put
this money into driver training
that's the way to fix it
but no we've got to restrict speed
limits that already happen as i said guy
boy 26 k's
and we want to change it down eventually
it's not on the slot but we want to
change it down i agree with some of
these roads i mean shingle roads you
know i don't have too much for a problem
with that in most cases
but other cases and i'm very much like
councillor barna when it comes to um
it comes to going against community
boards it's not something i want to do
and i don't do it lightly but there are
a whole percentage of people out there
who are against these new speed limits
and there is a whole lot of people who
are for them
democratically they'll be decided my
guess is that they'll just happen anyway
because new zealand's really good at
nanny state stuff we all sit around the
table in the pub and we moan our butt
off but do we do anything no we just let
it happen
okay uh councillor redmond
i just asked a question of staff
in table two on page
or 12 and diligent
uh the proposed speed limits all
compliant with the ncta formula or are
there any that depart from that
so which paper to help you
it's page 11 of the report eleven of
sixteen
page twelve and diligent
table two
proposed speed limits on rangiora rights
this is on the summary sorry i'm going
from the summary agenda it's a page 12
and 13.
intelligent page 12.
sorry just caught it catching up yeah
which table it's table two todd's road
fernside road flaxton road and john's
road
sorry can you repeat the question again
yes in that table table two are all
these proposed proposed speed limits
compliant with the nzta formula
or do any depart from it
um no they all comply with the safe and
appropriate space suggested by nzta
thank you any further speakers
just some right of reply i'm gonna
indicated support for this it's been
through a thorough process
i'm chair of the regional road safety
committee i do
see the road to zero material hey look i
appreciate the sentiments expressed by
colleagues around speed limits but um we
did go through this very carefully both
council williams myself as portfolio
holder and it came back
portfolio holders and it came back to
this table
uh where we had a really clear
discussion about that there could have
been a lot more on the table than was
this this was about finding that balance
which was rightly indicated by council
of arnold before where you're trying to
find
environment setting speed limits to the
environment
council williams and myself fronted a
meeting
down in flaxton road with some pretty
grumpy people really concerned about the
speeds past their properties and the
fact they couldn't get out
that was one of those uh meetings not
gonna it counts the atkinson's
absolutely right we're never going to
please everyone in this exercise it's
actually about uh having gone putting
faith in the process that we've been
through now we've been through it's been
through our community board i really do
urge
the majority of this council please do
support this today it would be a shame
if this didn't pass because i do think
that the work has been done
to to get to this point so i do urge
colleagues to support this this
afternoon
is it possible
at all for members to indicate ones that
they're actually concerned about and
have them voted on separately
i think i'd rather just vote on it
thank you um
well
you've you've had a workshop before
about this so there's been a lot
discussed about it so we're not going to
take i don't want to
go into individual road pieces now i
think we've we've had an adequate time
on it
so um
was it did someone else put their hand
up to speak no so that's no i've already
exercised foreign all those in favor
please say aye
contrary
goodness gracious
thank you
williams councillor redmond
councillor blackie
councillor barnett
council award yes
mayor gordon yes
stays at the current
service
that's right so it's the state status
quo
right
okay we come now to cairport to a hilly
board area
so is it sorry firstly any questions
sakai put two of you so you're moving
council of lekki
seconded by
i'll stick it up
goodness
counselor do you wish to speak yeah very
briefly it's the same problem it's a
pick the and mix factor you know there's
several things in there i don't like
much at all like putting charles street
all the way down to ash keaton ramp at
30 which is ridiculous and unenforceable
and who the hell is going to do that and
i don't like two speeds in giles road
two speeds in the same stretcher road
but when i said as you've just said
we're not going to dissect the thing
overall it's okay in the in the really
important bits like tram road um in
ireland road in our area
do need to come down very much so to 80.
don't need to add anything i think
you've adequately said does anyone else
wish to speak
i'll put the recommendation
sorry did you wish to speak
just briefly mr mayor i have a dilemma
in that i support some of the changes
and not others
and then for instance table one flaxton
road
um we have to have the speed limit the
same on both sides of the road
um
it is the dividing line between uh wards
i think
i think i might just
just can we just put press pause for a
moment i might just seek some advice on
this thanks
[Music]
do
so i've just taken this the pause robbie
it's about speed limits so i don't know
whether you want to remain or not
okay so um consulting with standing
orders there are a couple of options one
is that we
because we can revisit a decision
at after five days
uh and we could leave kaiapoi on the
table and consider them both at the same
time
if we wished the other is under 23.4
there is a provision that allows for a
revocation or alteration by resolution
at the same meeting
so it states that the meeting may revoke
or alter a previous resolution made at
the same meeting where during the course
of the meeting it receives fresh facts
or information concerning the resolution
in this situation 75 the members present
in voting must agree
to the revocation or alteration so
we're quite within our rights to do so
because of the new information that's
been presented by councillor edmund
if we were of a view to revoke i'm quite
prepared
just to signal that i'm to go through
the speeds line by line and we can
address those through that so
um
would there be general agreement that we
revoke the previous decision relating to
9.3 and if there was there would need to
be 75 support
of that
that's that's to do with the rengura the
speed changes for angular ashley ward
9.3
so is with 75 well can we just give an
indication of how many would support
that
well
the meeting continues we've got a quorum
um
so
it's it's not binding you by the way to
how you'll vote and the next one that's
entirely your call but it's addressing
an issue that's going to have a knock-on
effect
so would there be 75 can can you just
indicate by hand
yes
9.3 only
to revisit the decision
so so it's to use the the standing
orders which allow if 75 of members
present
can uh
can agree to revoke the previous
decision
so i just like a show of hands before we
consider that otherwise we'll just lay
it on the table the next item i would
suggest be laid on the table and be
revisited next time around
and that would be
so
can i get an indication who would be in
favor
so what would happen is that then it can
be reconsidered
and we take the measure line by line
and then we'll address the concerns of
the
i'd just like to yeah yep sorry
it's better that would be good going
line by nine but now i'd actually have
to go and sit down and make time to do
my line by line right because at this
stage okay i'm getting a clarity here
that there is not i don't think there's
75 support
so my suggestion would be then
that we
lay the
9.4 on the table
9.4
9.3 has been been well it's effectively
lost
so 9.4
i'm going to move that we lay that on
the table
and that will be considered at a future
meeting
seconded by council barnet
it's a procedural motion i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried
right
so
effectively what that means is that um
when five days have gone by then
the measures for rengar ashley can come
back so rengar ashley
will come to the next council meeting so
that will be february
and i would like to to to understand the
uh concerns of colleagues before we do
that next exercise suggest jared we
showed you a briefing
or a workshop
to discuss those and and get a greater
understanding of what those concerns are
before that comes back
through the chair i'd also like to
do a short presentation on two things
one
the safe system approach and how it
works as a package and two
how speed is a contributor to about a
third of the crashes in new zealand and
people dying being seriously injured
and
three give you a couple of real world
experiences of trying to get these
challenges through in other communities
but it's of no surprise speed's a very
emotive subject and compliance
new zealanders are not good at it but i
can tell you right now driver behaviour
takes generations to change so it's not
which is precisely why you're getting
some of the changes you're seeing on the
network so
if i could just give you five or ten
minutes of that would be helpful before
the next i think i think that could be
as part of the briefing in the lead up
to the next decision making like
can we do that during the week out from
the meeting so
try and find a time late late january uh
where we can before the february meeting
to make sure we're just clear and we
don't end up in a situation where
look honestly there's always going to be
times we just don't agree but having
this outcome is not ideal so we need to
find a way of seeing if there is
where the majority is sitting and where
the concern is
because we need
need for our staff to get some certainty
there in terms of process
all right okay
and as part of that jim could provide a
um some briefing on that broader package
ellie um thank you for all your work
cheers thanks jared
right we're at 19 item 10 now 10.1
jim
your health and safety report oh take
the reporters red just highlight a
couple of things obviously you've got a
session later this week with regard to
covert
a lot of work's gone on trying to
come up with a position
and we will be consulting with our staff
on a proposal as well
we have been looking at
lost time injuries so you're starting to
see that information 0.12 of
fte hours over the last three years
involved in lost time injury accidents
because that's a lead indicator
we're working
through the information we've got with
regard to contractors to see if we can
do better reporting back to you
at the moment we use site-wise
and most of our contractors are
pre-qualified and safe for the risk that
they're exposed to
but you've asked for better reporting
and we're looking to see what we can
bring back for them
thanks thanks jim any questions of jim
uh some are prepared to move
council awards secretary councillor
becky
i'll put the sorry we should not speak
no i just want to congratulate all the
staff from the team um
for well-being health and safety
that we um
embrace in waimakariri is
is top top marks to to everybody well
done
thanks joan
if you're the speakers i'll put the
recommendation all in favor please say
aye
contrary to clear at carriage
um now got recommendation 11.1 to 11.4
which is a series of minutes summer
someone's going to find them have they
is
thank you
all right so that's 11.1 to 11.4 that's
dealt with that's the minutes of
meetings
so we've i did put that resolution
adrian just double checking no
so this is the committee minutes for
information so that was moved and
seconded
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carriage
community board minutes for information
are contained that's 12.1 to 12.4 some
are prepared to move
if that's the balance you can account
for blacky
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried no
correspondence
my diary page is 811 to 815 so i'm
prepared to move moved to council awards
seconded by councillor redmond
um
do you wish to speak
i'll put what
i just say it's it's near the end of the
year and
and and you've done a great job and uh
we just hope you rest over christmas
thank you joe yes is everyone so thank
you for those kind comments i'll put
that all those in favor please say oh
contrary to clear it carried come to
council portfolio updates
au ewe relationships there really isn't
a lot to report apart from um
we did have a the um
renault liaison meeting and it was a
really good meeting
there are a number of items that came
out of that
mahitahi which is scheduled for next
tuesday ended up with actually only one
agenda item
on that
and in consultation with the co-chair
tanya we've agreed to um
cancel that meeting and it'll be held
next uh next year
so it was no point in bringing it all
together for one report effectively so
that's where that measures ash oh sorry
one thing we did through district plan
um
i did i was aware that the submission
did come in from the ewe which
um which was good to see that they
submitted on the proposed district plan
so that was good to see
all right um
grant christchurch partnership update um
effectively
uh we've got a meeting on friday um
and there'll be a couple of updates
around mess rapid transit um
also the greater christchurch 2050
project and you were part of a briefing
this morning which
indicates around the the spatial
planning and the work that's underway
there
it's all
feeding into that broader work that's
going on with the partnership at the
moment so the partnership's in good
heart
and
there is a matter which is circulating
on the christchurch city council naked
around a transport
linkage in the city i
will see how that goes on their
respective councils but it's to put a
case to the transport minister to do
further investment in
a christchurch city certainly around a
commuting
area there i have to say myself i'm
not opposed to that suggestion but the
uh it's it's
it's the consequences it has on our rate
payers that i want to understand and
would prefer that's workshop with the
partners before it progresses further
so we understand that broader
perspective any questions
category water management strategy
council stewards uh unable to be here
she has provided
a report
here which i'm happy to to hand around
but
i won't go into it for the purposes of
time at the moment but as you can
as you'll be aware um
council stuart always gives a very
thorough um report on this so she's
given some good points so i'll hand that
round the table for members and adrian
if you can maybe just put some bullets
in the report
okay uh international relationship
stupidity is um
not able to be here um
but he
uh the um
pescendale um trust did
um present recently through a meet
recently and they're progressing on a
pamphlet and also
there are some items which were part of
the christchurch harry say
which
were medallions gifted by the belgium
government and
there is a view to bring those back to
our district which is trying to locate
them presently
and then there'll be a decision as to
where they're located but the trust
isn't is going well they're looking at
two seats one either end and some
plantings so
councillor deputy americans doing a good
job uh leading that with our recipes
um regen council becky
mr mayor
as you all know aqualand opened last
weekend weekend and a bit ago
dan and i were several of the
councillors were there so i won't dwell
on it at any length um
just to say it kicked off well they got
100 i got 250 people that weekend
as the kickoff weekend and i checked
with them
jason this morning and they got a 180
this weekend just gone
um of which 20 were one of their freebie
sessions that they're giving to under i
don't think that was a school i think it
was an underprivileged group so they're
up and running we've only had one
one complaint about the whole thing and
that's from a hardy annual who complains
at about 20 minute intervals about about
the the project so all is good and the
locals have embraced it
um community hub on whatever day it was
last week um thursday afternoon we had a
drop-in session
for consultation with the hub in on on
site
and it was quite interesting
dan and i were there and a couple of
community board members and about eight
staff and about six men shared people
and several foods food satisfy rescue
people and uh we got three people from
the public arrived well dan and i left
after nearly an hour because it was
boring and only two had turned up by
then and i gather only one one turned up
after we left which is a bit of a lesson
it is quite easy to over consult in
these matters and i think we we do over
consult a bit and it also is a credit to
the start to green space staff because
it shows that the previous consult the
one we had indoors with the with the big
scale model which a lot of them turned
up to they were totally
empowered and and educated and
understood so
that's um that looks to be going well
thank you
thanks council councilman just for the
recall that i didn't leave because it
was boring i left because i had another
commitment to go to but
it was very good and i was encouraged by
it so just want to say that for the
record
thank you um climate change and
sustainability council meetings
this was there's it's it's been a slow
news day for me particularly but um
behind the scenes have been a few things
happening um the
at long last the canterbury climate
change risk assessments come out
um the final report's been received and
we're currently just weighing up what
its district level implications are
um and also the
niwa climate change scenario is for the
waimakariri district that brief's been
finalized
and the outputs will include a summary
report in a video to provide a good
basis for community conversations on
climate change
a couple consultations and reviews going
on one on the carbon emissions reduction
and we have put into submissions by the
gcp the mayoral forum and taitura and to
that discussion document towards a
confirmed national plan to be released
in may 22 alongside the 22 budget
and also
council as well as cmf and taitura
submissions
have been put in for the waste strategy
legislation review
and um as for our district emissions
profile that's kind of still sitting out
there we're finalizing the brief for
that and we're going to have a
competitive bidding process because
there are quite a few
different providers that um
we're trying to coordinate with other
councils to do that with
on the
on the smaller scale what we in this
organization are doing the goal has just
come out if you've seen it or not and
in property our linda has come up with
a new recycling feature which will
hopefully soon feature in part of the
green space area on the western side of
215 high street which will have
cardboard recycling mixed recycling
green and organics compostable
plant-based wrappings and coffee cups
pla
and
landfill
and they'll um
they plan on on weighing the um the bins
weekly and reporting through
um in a sustainability report for
council um to audit and give us some
feedback
needed for the three bin system and how
that's working so
um
i think that's probably enough
thanks council meetings any questions
and they're also working on a community
soft plastics pick up too so fingers
crossed we get something happening with
that
thanks nikki business promotion town
centres joan
thank you um
i
wasn't able to attend a zoo meeting last
tuesday which heather
um cheered so um that was
peter from
oxford they've got and planning is
underway for wings and wheels to be held
in april up at oxford
and planning to celebrate matariki
somehow next year also in oxford there's
new people there in oxford and they seem
to be peter they're getting
very enthusiastic and getting some
action in the oxford promotions
association so that's good ross um also
got to go to a meeting a special meeting
straight after this meeting for angular
promotions um we're still planning for
eats and beats at the end of march
um and um
we're running as is kai poi christmas
raffles to try and because their
sponsorship has all um
you know we can't have our sponsorship
if we are not running events
um so we're trying to sort of put some
money in the kitty by running raffles as
you all know so thank you everybody hope
somebody wins a nice prize
um
so um
so yeah there's lots of things that
we're looking to do um
there's a christmas um competition in
rangura that's being run by which is
bailey's real estate have printed
hundreds of um
coloring sheets for the christmas
competition so that's underway
um uh
so also um heather mentioned that
property market heather told the others
about a report from benji pedersen
outlining the number of aucklanders
moving to waimakariri 1200 either to
send report to others so everybody's
wanting to come to live in waimakariri
and why shouldn't they
um and um of course kaipou are running a
christmas raffle as well
and um
i think they've decided not to do the
kaiapoi river they can't run the kaipa
river carnival which is because of all
the restrictions which is really sad
um
heather at enterprise north canterbury
um of course went we all went to the
aqua
land opening which was
really good we hope that goes well for
them
the visited guide and walking cycling
guide for the district 20
20 000 is fully funded by advertisers
printing 25 000 copies which is great
visit visit waimakariri have organised
four campaigns over four seasons using
all media platforms
um most of our events have been
cancelled
business awards were wrapped up and we
had a look at the winners on zoom
um but we hope to have something in
february to present trophies and
certificates to finalists and winners
um
[Music]
let me see that um
enterprise north canterbury has a new
brand logo after 15 years
and their major effect event fund is
looking very healthy over four years so
there's time to think and plan for one
so all we want is the ability to be able
to do it so that we can start
actively engaging in the community and
giving people some fun times so
we have a little issue and with the
regular promotions and letter events
yes
may not want to raise that joke okay yes
yes so that's something that we have to
discuss tonight so
thank you cheers
nikki first thank you so i i know we've
had a lot of cancellations um but but
you say that the eats and beats might
is going ahead is that going to be a
vaccine pass um
because it's um held in park they can
control the entry by making sure
everybody um they they show their um as
they come in so i'm sure we can run that
do you have a question
like
except for portfolio updates so i've got
no questions no urgent general business
we're scheduled for the uh
briefing at 4 30 is that correct
yep yep yes it's 4 30.
so um we're now going to move into
public excluded so sorry doug
um
just wait a minute while we
get the machinery
[Music]